only 450 are going to be released so
who's gonna be buying these well that's
a very good question I mean a lot of
collectors clearly this is a last in a
series of sex we've produced started off
in 2005 with the release of the first of
their special edition which reflected
our exceptional cast shadow casts so
there'll be a few collectors looking to
get the whole series of sex but also
there are connoisseurs out there that
really do want to know drink a bit of
history and this is an opportunity for
them as well okay and i'm not a whisky
drinker per saying I've had I've had
some of course but what's so special
about this what's so different well as
you mentioned this is the the oldest
whisky we've produced in commercial
quantity we do have whisky going back to
the 1920s but this is really a
commercial release of 450 bottles and
really we're special about it is you
know you drink a little bit of history
you know you're going back in time the
youngest whiskey in its 65 years old
there are older whiskies in it and so
you're really going back to that year of
joining the war and post-war era so
everything you said you're something
history I wonder Paul how important is
it I mean does older whiskey isn't
always better does it does it always
make it better if it's another decade or
two or three or four decades old not
necessarily I mean aging is a really
important aspect of whiskey production
and certainly you know Scotch whiskies
been known for older whiskies throughout
the world but really it's about the
quality of the old cast shoes we are
sales of Macallan we we use
predominantly sherry oak casks from
Spain we produce about 92 percent of the
world's sherry old casks there were 10
times the price of a bourbon cask and
really you know the color which is 100%
natural comes from the wood so therefore
it's incredibly important you invest at
the beginning of that that process in
exceptional oak casks so if you use a
really good cask sixty-five years later
it's really really good if you don't use
a good cask at the beginning may not be
so good so really it's about the whole
process Paul I I'm a big fan of the
brown liquors but I'm kind of an old guy
I went last night to the Soho House and
Prince Laur burg and hung out with the
cool young kids after I took off my
necktie I was allowed in they were all
drinking some kind of
Shoal genes that were made up with super
cool recipes are you getting are you
getting a little bit of competition from
the gins and the other sort of clear
spirits these days I wouldn't call it
competition I mean I think what's
happening at the moment is we're seeing
a new interest in spirits generally the
cocktail culture is here to stay as
amongst as you said you know a younger
generation are now beginning to
experiment with bourbon Irish scotch
whiskey gins and that's just great for
all of us at the Macallan we are a
little bit more expensive than a regular
gin but in good time some of those young
folk you were hanging out with in Berlin
are no doubt going to be drinking
Macallan ok Paul so is there a special
way that you need to market this at all
I mean given that it is going to go to a
very exclusive buyer I mean is there a
special way that you're presenting this
no I mean I think you know we're really
at the Macallan focusing it was on the
glass in the glass at the end of the day
it's about the liquid and in the process
it gets it to this exceptional stage
I mean products that there's tend to end
up in the secondary market at auction a
lot of them are drunk as well and
Macallan is enjoyed traditionally about
25 percent in the global or should
market by value so we tend to look just
alike
what of mouth and and just generally the
people who know the best in life come to
us and so we don't market anything of
this nature it's just not necessary
right it's so exclusive